i mean of course he wants a guy who can
get the ball down the field
and ryan tannehill see people like to
lock into their narrative yeah
tell them go ahead there's still that
group out there
that hears ryan tannehill and
immediately thinks sucks
yeah because they came to that
conclusion when he was with the dolphins
ryan tannehill sucks ryan tannehill he's
no good
ryan tannehill he can't play and he's a
prime example of a guy that
that unlike the vast majority of
quarterbacks who come into the nfl
especially first rounders
who get three years max nowadays
to figure it out you know we talk about
that all the time
ryan tannehill is the exception to that
ryan tannehill
got eight years in miami yeah before
they finally decided
we we just we have to move on right
we've we've determined after eight years
that you're not going to be a franchise
quarterback and never will be
and then he goes to tennessee and he
instantly
becomes a franchise quarterback well
and most people can't can't process that
yeah it's six years not eight just to
correct you
12 13 14 15 16 17 18. it was seven years
seven years there we go seven years cool
all right
and and you're right that's how most
people do look at ryan tannenhill
they get knocked in and locked into the
narrative that's right
and then there first off let me just say
as you've heard and we've discussed many
times
the narrative was freaking wrong like
get over yourselves your narrative was
wrong
like the the miami dolphins in his seven
years
made the golden rule of how to screw up
a top ten pick
and not make your quarterback a
franchise quarterback see they're trying
not to do that this time around with tua
but they did everything you know we've
talked about with the teams that do
something wrong with a franchise
quarterback it's why we brought up the
sam darnold conversation
so much early on in free agency and
stuff with like sam darnold and all that
it's the same thing what did the
dolphins do to
to like to bring ryan tannehill up
what did they do support wise i mean yes
adam gase was there
solid offense nothing special nobody's
gonna write books about oh my gosh adam
gase's offense is the greatest we've
seen in the history of the nfl
that's not gonna happen nobody's gonna
write about the talent there
they never gave him a chance and anybody
that was really paying attention went
wait he's doing way better than people
realize
and he's actually one of the stars of
the football team but since they weren't
going to the playoffs we just oh they
lost blaming on the quarterback
blaming on you know ryan tannehill who
doesn't look that cool or whatever i
don't know
the results are phenomenal the last few
years to what you're talking about and
he's one of the best down the field
passers in all of football
i mean that and these are not garbage
time stats or anything
like that but that's where it fits
they're a power throwing football team
they want to run the ball and then they
want to run play action
and throw down the field and strike deep
for explosive plays
and ryan tannehill's as good as it gets
in football the last two years at that
and that's where the marriage is is
really damn good and yeah i'm taking
tannehill over matt ryan right now
and let's remember this 2016 gays first
season as head coach of the dolphins
they made it to the playoffs and
tannehill was having a great season
that's right by calyas campbell
in a game against the cardinals messed
up his knee and
and this is when the dolphins made their
most fateful medical decision since
rejecting drew brees
they decided not to have the acl
reconstructed right
because they thought that 601 half a
dozen the other
a partially torn acl which doesn't heal
on its own
versus a fully reconstructed acl we'll
take our chances
and then early in training camp 2017 pop
goes the acl and that's it for ryan
tannehill so
um you know it's just unfortunate that
that happened because he was
finally coming around in miami and
and now that the titans are getting the
benefit of it uh and
uh and now you throw julio jones into
the mix and it's only gonna be better
here's
okay go ahead i'm gonna ask you like
do we do i've been thinking about it for
like the last you know 24 hours here i
mean
is there can you think of a trade for a
receiver
really in modern history here or
anything like that that
it's it's these two type of caliber
players now
at receiver together at the same time am
i missing one that's
obvious i mean i know we've had some
good ones but not where we're like
whoa there's a top ten recipe from
welker moss that's about that's where i
came to right
right okay right and and to me that's
still even though it's
moss and welker is not as great as these
two
because welker is awesome as he was
isn't just the
pure physical specimen that aj brown is
like where you can just go
well we don't really need to like do a
lot of plays to get you open you're just
a freak get open
like that's the kind of guy he is that
to me is where it's special too
i mean it's it's rare that we see this
type of move with that type of player
already being there
on the roster and going we're gonna get
one just like him
how about that deal with that defenses
that's where i really think it's cool
and let's hear from ryan tannehill
regarding his reaction
to the trade that brings julio jones to
town
i'm excited i'm fired up you know it's
been a uh been a little bit up and down
didn't know if it was going to happen or
not
uh just kind of long for the ride like
everybody else and um
you know my agent called me today and
said i said it was going to happen so
i'm excited you know excited to bring
julio on board
to pair him up across from aj on the
other side you know it's a really
dynamic
dynamic duo for our side receivers so
looking forward to what he can bring to
table obviously a lot of work in front
of us
gonna have to feel each other out and
get on the same page but
looking forward to the work and i'm
looking forward to the good things fired
up you know i'm
excited to not be excited to play with
the guy from the caliber of talent that
julio is and has been for his whole
career so i'm excited to get to know him
as a person
and um and just welcome him to the team
and
and
get them acclimated to the way we do
things
well you know i know the world's getting
back to normal i think that's the first
time in a year and a half that i had
had to really focus on what a guy was
saying because there was actually
background
what's background noise yeah what's that
are people in a room together what the
hell is going on here
uh i mean how could he not be excited i
mean really
how could he not be you know it's a
quarterback's dream come true
really it is in a lot of ways now it's
just like we talked about with some
other quarterbacks this offseason
you know people are going to expect big
results now but it shouldn't change
anything for tana hill he's been given
big results the last two years his
statistics have been as good as
the top quarterbacks in football so he
shouldn't panic
but man that i mean quarterback's
dreaming wait we got a good offensive
line
coach likes to run the ball wow that's
great and we got a just a superstar
running back
as good as we've ever seen and now those
two guys where
yeah they can get open and run any of
any route but they're also those two
type of guys mike where
you know quarterback loves it oh they're
covered oh i got people around
me let me just throw to number 11. let
me just throw to number eight i know
they're covered but who cares
you know oh my god i got it well i'm not
that surprised that's what they do
i mean that's just it's amazing he's got
to feel really really good today
at the risk of being accused of applying
a jinx because i'm not i'm not i think
this is a fair question at this point
guys get injured tannehill got knocked
out for a full season got knocked out
for part of a season then was gone for a
full season
i'm looking at their roster right now
deshawn kaiser and logan woodside
are the alternatives behind ryan tano
it's not like there's a bunch of
veterans out there
but i think that to the extent that
there are
or will be tennessee suddenly becomes an
attractive spot for a veteran
who's looking to be ready to go yes
in the event yeah the starter gets
injured uh agreed
in fact i think when you make this type
of move tennessee's got to be the team
that now has to protect themselves for
that
you know just like we've seen new
orleans do sean payton was always smart
enough to go wait
we're a super bowl team i'm not gonna
just let like oh our quarterback got
hurt and hey screw you you guys the
other 52 guys
we're not gonna make it the quarterback
got hurt it's over let's go home
like that's where yes now now that's
probably something they're going to have
to think and keep on their radar here
because you have gone to a
super bowl caliber football team now you
got to protect your interests
and i wouldn't trust logan woodside no
disrespect to you logan
or deshawn kaiser just not enough
experience
and and not proven enough to be able to
take over the realm of this type of team
like this so
uh i would think that's something
they're gonna they're gonna keep their
eye on
as best i can tell the guys that are out
there right now
rg3 matt barkley
is he still out there i believe he's
still out there yeah i would think he
was somebody you think about
you guys nick mullins is still out there
you want him nope negative ghost rider
um i'm sorry i'm gonna quit i'm gonna
quit but but i
i like the barkley idea that's not the
worst all right but the other you know
like we've talked about too i i think
and and you you've said this
training what about alex smith coming
out of retirement well to be the backup
i'd think twice i think not not that
he's going to get the ball down the
field to julio jones but if i'm alex
that's the kind of guy you like yeah
yeah right you know just like
somebody's ready to go and come in and
play and get the ball distributed
exactly he'll be smart he'll take care
of the ball
we gotta we fixed our defense tennessee
this offseason they're gonna be hoping
for that so
yeah i mean and and of course we know
there'll be training camp casualties and
things like that to where they'll be
able to address it probably at the end
of august at some point
and go oh wait some team's gonna get rid
of a veteran
here we go come here this is a great
spot i would think that's gotta be on
their radar
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports